the main objective of this regulation is
the simplification of dcap the proposal
is a part of the midterm review of the
multi-annual financial framework of the
EU and simplifies the procedures for
both farmers and administrative bodies
in the member states based on the
information about the current situation
presented by Phil Hogan we concluded
that in a milker there is a certain a
stabilization of prices with a big meat
noting some increase in prices it's
important that member states understand
the context of the Omnibus as part of
the mff midterm review it is also not
intended to include the more
controversial proposals which will have
to be dealt with in the context of
proposals that we would be bringing
forward for the cap 2020 I know hope
that all three institutions can move
forward to reach a mutually acceptable
agreement in time for the measures that
are included in the Omnibus to enter
into force on the first of January 2018
our today's agreement on fishing quotas
for the Baltic Sea was adopted
unanimously and represents a good
compromise which is in line with the
Baltic Sea plan member states agreed to
reduce the catch of eastern code by
twenty-five percent western code by 56%
then herring in the gulf of riga by
eleven percent and soleman by twenty
percent member states have also agreed
to agree to increase the catch of place
herring sprout let me underline in
particular discernment and emblematic
species of the baltic where i have
proposed attempt percent increase thanks
to our efforts in previous years also i
particularly welcome the twenty percent
cut off salman in the gulf of finland
but the protection of our fishermen is
also very close to our heart and I could
not leave our fishermen to deal with
such significant quota cuts alone
especially for the smallest of our
fishing businesses who will be most
vulnerable I informed ministers that the
European maritime and Fisheries fund is
available to them in order to support
industry during this difficult bout but
hopefully short period